when you make a composite airplane you
make these giant wing and fuselage parts
and they asked us for a better way to
stick them together because the joints
were a place of failure and what we
discovered was instead of making a few
big Parts if you make little Loops of
carbon fiber
and you reversibly link them in joints
and you do it in a special geometry that
balances being under constrained and
over constrained with just the right
degrees of freedom we set the world
record for the highest modulus
ultralight material just by if in effect
making carbon fiber Lego
so the so lightweight materials are
crucial for Energy Efficiency this let
us make that the lightest weight High
modulus material we then showed that
with just just a few part types we can
tune the material properties and then
you can create really wild robots that
instead of having a tool the size of a
jumbo jet to make a jumbo jet you can
make little robots that walk on these
cellular structures to build the
structures where they error correct
their position on the structure and they
navigate on the structure and so using
all of that with
um NASA we made more airplanes a former
student Kenny
Chung and Ben Jeanette made a morphing
airplane the size of NASA Langley's
biggest wind tunnel with Toyota we've
made super efficiency race cars we're
right now looking at projects with NASA
to build these for things like space
telescopes and space habitats where the
ribosome who I mentioned a little while
back can make an elephant one molecule
at a time ribosomes are slow they run at
about one molecule a second but
ribosomes make ribosomes so you have
thousands of them trillions of them and
that makes an elephant in the same way
these little assembly robots I'm
describing can make giant structures
uh at heart because of the robot can
make the robot so more recently to my
students Amira and Miana had a nature
communication paper showing how this
robot can be made out of the parts it's
making so the robots can make the robot
so you build up the capacity of robotic
assembly you can self-replicate can you
Linger on what that robot looks like
what is a robot it can walk along and do
error correction and what is a robot
that can self-replicate uh from the
materials that is given what does that
look like what are we talking so um this
is fascinating yeah the answer is
different at different length scales so
so to explain that in biology primary
structure is the code in the messenger
RNA that says what the ribosome should
build yeah
um secondary structure or geometrical
motifs they're things like helices or
sheets tertiary structures are
functional elements like electron donors
or acceptors quaternary structure is
things like molecular Motors that are
moving my mouth or making the synapses
work in my brain so there's that
hierarchy of primary secondary tertiary
quaternary
now what's interesting is
if you want to buy Electronics today
from a vendor there are hundreds of
thousands of types of resistors or
capacitors or transistors huge inventory
all of biology is just made from this
inventory of 20 Parts amino acids and by
composing them you can create all of
life
and so
as part of this digitization of
materials
we're in effect trying to create
something like amino acids for
engineering creating all of Technology
from 20 Parts I
um I see as another discretion I helped
started an office for science in
Hollywood and
um there was a fun thing for the movie
The Martian where I did a program with
Bill Nye and a few others on how to
actually build a civilization on Mars
that they described in a way that I like
as I was talking about how to go to Mars
without luggage and the at heart it's
sort of how to create life in non-living
materials so if if you think about this
primary secondary tertiary quaternary
structure
um in my lab we're doing that but on
different length scales for different
purposes so we're making micro robots
out of like Nano bricks and to make the
robots to build large-scale structures
in Space the elements of the robots now
are centimeters rather than micrometers
and so the assembly robots for the
bigger structures are
uh there are the cells that make up the
structure but then we have functional
cells and so cells that can process and
actuate each cell can like move one
degree of Freedom or attach or disk
detach or process now those elements I
just described we can make out of the
still smaller parts So eventually
there's the hierarchy of the little
Parts make little robots that make
bigger parts of bigger robots that up
through that hierarchy in that way you
can move up the landscape right early on
I tried to go in a straight line from
the bottom to the top and that ended up
being a bad idea instead we're kind of
doing all of these in parallel and then
they're growing together and so to make
the larger scale structures we um like
there's a lot of a hype right now about
3D printing houses where you have a
printer the size of the house we're
right now working on using swarms of
these you know table scale robots that
walk on the structures to place the
parts much more efficiently that's
amazing but you're saying you can't for
now go from the very small to the very
large that'll come
um that'll come in stages